starting off this hour is going to be
Detroit Michigan Anthony is with us i
Anthony how are you hey Dave I'm great
how are you better than I deserve what's
up in your world hey Dave so my wife and
I just recently sold our home our
proceeds were 55,000 we currently have
about sixty two thousand dollars in debt
when we sold the house we moved in with
my in-laws so my question for you is
should we take those proceeds knock out
a majority of our debt live with our
in-laws for a little bit in power save
for a down payment on our new place or
should I use my equity that I received
for a down payment
and just hit the debt snowball hard -
what's your household income 145 good
for you yeah and how many children do
you have one daughter how old three
months okay so what's your timeframe to
be with the in-laws if we pay off the
debt with this money and power shut out
of them probably nine months to a year
okay can you do that yeah we have a
great relationship will you then I
believe so but I can't tell the future
but hopefully yeah I think I think we
was okay because not many people can do
this all right everybody everybody talks
about it because they like the math but
at the end of that math is a clogged up
bathroom you know I mean there's just ya
know and stinky diapers and everything
else right so they're cute for a few
minutes but Oh Lord uh yeah I I'm going
to use the money to pay off the debt
either way okay okay and clear the data
and with your income you're going to be
debt-free in 20 minutes and then you're
going you're not quite getting quite got
enough to do it but you'll be there very
very quickly right now and then then as
you said we're going to save our
emergency fund empower save into a down
payment even if that means that after
six months this experiment the social
experiments gone badly and you have to
go rent something for six months yeah
I'd be okay with that if that if that
enters into the equation more okay than
I would just going and buying something
right now
okay okay so I'm going to I'm going to
revert to the baby steps with what
you're doing because this is your
shortest path to wealth
it's your shortest path to home
ownership with meaning okay right and
this idea that we just have to buy a
house like our hair's on fire or we're
all going to hell or something is crazy
all right and so I want everybody to buy
houses I just want you to own the house
I don't want it to own you and I want
you to get your your financial act
together in the process and so when
broke people buy houses it makes them
broker that's why they call them
mortgage brokers so um so I like your
plan and I like that phrase I haven't
used that phrase I may steal it
power-save yeah yeah that's good because
that what that tells me is you're
totally focused intense you're not going
to be running off and going oh we're
going to do like two weeks in the
Bahamas while we're power shaving that's
not power saving
that's like loosing and so a power
saving is head-down game on baby right
and that that's what you're doing it and
you got it man I like it so that yes
that's exactly what I would do but even
if you need to move out and rent for a
little while till you get your down
payment up because the social experiment
fails that wouldn't make you bad people
by the way it just means we all didn't
live in same house together anymore
and that's an okay thing and our family
we love each other but we're going to
live in same house we love each other
but we want to keep loving each other
and so we know better I mean it's it
just you know
yeah it grandparenting is good when they
don't live in your house it's harder
when they live in your house so um yeah
I got two of them this week by the way
the parents went on vacation and left
them with us which is dangerous for
everyone involved the parents the kids
the grandparents everyone is at risk
when this happens you know because Papa
Dave does some stuff that with the
little boy I mean who William I mean you
know you can probably shouldn't do it
but I'm gonna ditch I can do it so cuz
it you left on my mate so see that's
what happens so we've already had some
adventures this weekend that's right me
and the boy and the dog that's right we
got out there stirring up some stuff so
breaking some stuff that's good that's
good so hey but are you living with him
now now not full-time I love them I take
a bullet for them but they can't live
with me
so you guys work it out yeah I hope it
well I hope you can do it I'm and if you
can more power to you it's a wonderful
thing it's a wonderful thing but I think
I'm just too contrary like being an
empty nester I've liked every phase of
raising our kids I like them when they
were tiny and they were cute and cuddly
and all that stuff and then I liked them
when they weren't and I didn't have to
change their clothes for them that was
awesomeness when that broke through and
then I liked them when they went off to
school and then when they could like
play sports and stuff that was cool -
that was fun I liked teenagers we had
good teenagers I mean there were
teenagers but they were good teams I
liked and I like them when they were in
college and I liked them as adults a lot
they're they're fun as an adult I like
them when they left when I moved out I
liked them then and I like them when
they come back and bring the grandbabies
Rachel came over and brought a million
last night so all of them are hanging
out with us last night
so I've loved every phase of it but I
didn't love any of them enough to want
to go back to those phases that's like
if you're ones people says the best
years of your life were in high school
that means that you and hey much of a
life that's what that means if the best
years of your life were and when you're
in high school you're like uncle rink
RIT Rico on Napoleon Dynamite right I
mean it's the best years of your life
were in high school you had a life
really if the best years of your kids
lives view with your kids is not the
last few that you've had
then you're not you're not growing
you're not changing so grand parenting
is awesomeness I don't know how great
this was going to be
I'd have been nicer to their parents I
mean you know really so but it's a
social experiment to move in together if
you guys can pull that off man go for it
I'm with you I got your back
I love it go for it and the power safe
thing that's that's the magic it's a
magic phrase to our whole conversation
right there so go get after it man and
call us and let us know when you're
debt-free and then when you get to buy
your next home and then when you get
that one paid off and wow you're heading
off in the right dress
it's good stuff embrace the phases of
your life embrace where you are squeeze
every ounce of life out of every time
that you have don't be sitting there
going you know I once the teenagers are
gone now enjoy the teenagers ah once
they're out of diapers now enjoy them
while they're in diapers are cute
they're cuddly they're dependent at that
point they're fun honest I used to say
if mine would have stayed a little out I
had 23 but that's just not true I really
wouldn't because they weren't going to
stay little anyway they grew up with
cars and colleges and stuff and weddings
oh yeah that one that goes into budget
too cool yeah it's an adventure you guys
this thing we do call family isn't it
and then then a wonderful one and you
got to get your act together to be able
to live it and live it wide open pedal
to the metal baby this is how we do it
around here this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]